[Musique]
protégez réalisée en mai elle va que
j'étais plus nerveux qu'un soir de
première de thé à la barre est haute
pour luc guérin benoît brière et martin
drainville
ils incarneront les nouveaux visages de
brou mené contourna de théâtre québécois
[Musique]
après plus de trois mille
représentations brou a pris fin en avril
mais les demandes pour reprendre les
textes sur scène ont été très nombreuses
les auteurs étaient là pour en témoigner
et ce n'est pas par hasard comme lui sur
ses trios il ya plusieurs plusieurs
années mais celle côté aurait dit si un
jour on arrête ya 3 go qui pourraient
personnes l'ont brillamment train de
révéler le guérer quelqu'un me rapporter
ça quand on a su que les jeux les gars
étaient on sait juste manifestions ses
dictées si un jour vous cherchez une
troupe pour prendre la suite
nous autres sur la roulette de
disquettes comprendront pas notre numéro
bien sûr ils savent tous les trois que
les comparaisons seront inévitables
disette après différence avec quelque
chose de différent
alors est ce qu'on est en train de
réinventer le bouton 4 ou pas du tout ce
serait bien
culotté de notre part je pense que
d'autres sont équipés question talent je
pense que en plus c'est trop orgueilleux
qui ont travaillé ensemble beaucoup qui
ont une troupe ensemble depuis plusieurs
années sur ces bonnes important c'est un
peu sur le même modèle que nous on était
savez que vous avez entraîné mais un
texte monument est là comment vous allez
arriver à passer ce ce serait cela je
n'en ai aucune idée
bout a été vu par plus de 3 millions de
spectateurs
mais les auteurs comme les comédiens
sont convaincus que la pièce demeure un
portrait de société intemporel et bruce
est un portrait juste précis
chirurgicale d'un québec qui existent au
jo même si les femmes viennent à la
taverne ici julie jasmin boudreau radio
canada montréal